- So have you met Chloe?
- I've never met both of you.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
You never met Drax?
- I know, I know.
- How - you're married to Chris Pratt.
- I know, it's very bizarre.
- How are you?
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Well, I'm just bringing people together.
- I know, it was so funny
cause I told my husband
I was coming on this show
and he's like, "Oh my
god, that's so amazing."
I was like, I know I've
heard so much about you,
but I have never met you so.
- [Kelly] That's hilarious.
- Thrilled to finally meet you.
- Yeah, likewise.
- Oh my gosh, I love those movies:
The Guardians of the Galaxy.
Okay, anyway, I'm fine, I'm fine.
So your husband though,
he just, Chris Pratt,
he had a birthday, right?
A recent birthday, what'd you get him?
- I got him piggies.
- [Kelly] You got him actual pigs?
- Yeah, I did.
- What, like miniature ones?
- No, no, well actually
what happened to me
when I was in high school was I rescued
this supposed miniature pig
when I lived at my parents house,
and it turned into a giant potbelly pig
and rooted up my mom's entire lawn.
- I'm just laughing because
if nobody's actually had a huge
potbelly, they're enormous.
- They're so big, very, very large.
Yeah that's Bacon, my pig,
she's since passed away.
- You named her bacon.
- I know, my little brother Christopher
actually named her
Bacon so it's his fault.
But yeah, he has, we have an amazing place
in Washington state so
there's a lot of land there,
so these pigs are not living with us,
they're living in like
a very beautiful farm.
- [Kelly] On a farm, yeah.
- Loving life, very large
now so I'm very excited
that they did not come to our house
because I was told they would stay small.
They did not.
- Yeah, I was told my dog
was gonna be miniature
and lies and deception.
Heffer's like forty-five pounds.
I'm like what, he is not
fifteen to eighteen pounds.
That's awesomeness, y'all
have a farm in Washington?
Washington's beautiful.
- Yeah, yeah it's very nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, beautiful.
- [Kelly] Nice place
to escape, that's cool.
- Yeah, I grew up around
animals so it's really fun.
- [Kelly] I did as well.
- I love it, It makes me so happy.
- Animals are so cool.
They're just loyal and nice
and they're never mean.
So have y'all ever had any unusual pets?
- I used to have this babysitter
and she had a rooster.
- Oh, they can be mean.
- [Katherine] Yeah, and loud.
- That's the thing.
It was very mean cause
she would go outside
and she loved the rooster
because how can you not love animals?
And she would go outside
and try to bond with it,
and it would try to bite her.
And at a certain point,
it was chasing her all around the yard,
and she climbed up a tree,
and it bit her butt, and it was horrible.
- Oh my god, that's what happened to me.
One time at a little
petting zoo, my sister,
I was holding her child,
and this goat kept nipping at my behind.
I was like, "Get your child off of me!"
Cause I was holding her
kid like from the goat
and like, my sister is just laughing.
I'm like, "It's eating my butt!"
I was like, "Quick!"
Anyway, no I love random pets though,
I love, I love all kinds
of pets, especially farms.
It's nice to get out
in like the wilderness,
where they're out of the city.
- I like having them in like a
home in the city though, too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I also grew up like that.
My dad has a miniature
pony and a donkey currently
that he brings in the house constantly.
- [Kelly] In your house?
- In his house, yes.
- Oh good, correction, in his house.
You can do whatever
you want in your house.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] Okay, well let's
talk about your book.
So The Gift of Forgiveness,
what inspired you to do this?
- Really just life.
I think I, you know,
felt as many of us do,
like I was struggling with
forgiveness in my own life
and I went to try and
find help and resources
and I couldn't find anything
that really spoke to me.
And I felt that speaking to other people
about their journeys and their struggles
is really what inspired me
to be able to go to my life
and practice forgiveness.
So I decided to create that.
This book has a series
of incredible stories
that are just really mind
blowing and these people
have all been able to talk
about practicing forgiveness
and struggling with forgiveness
and some still struggling with it,
so it's a really awesome story.
- I think it's amazing
cause even though sometimes
in my life I feel like I
have forgiven a situation,
then you're like,
"Oh, this isn't just
like a one time thing,
"I have to keep practicing at this."
Like, because I don't
think I did fully forgive.
- Yeah, and it was actually
something interesting
that was in the book and also interesting
cause people are always like,
"Okay, so what's the quick fix
"on how do I practice forgiveness?"
And I keep reminding people that
what forgiveness means to
you is something totally
than what it means to me which makes it
so much more complicated
but also really interesting
because for a lot of us,
it's a one and done thing
which in my book, there are some people
who practice forgiveness and
they're done and they're good.
And then there are a
lot of us, like myself,
who it's an ongoing process
and so what I like to say to people
is that I have struggled with forgiveness
and I've been able to practice it
but I'm a fellow
struggler with forgiveness
and it's an ongoing process.
But when I struggle, I'm
able to now draw inspiration
from the stories in my book
to kind of help get me through
and that's been incredibly helpful for me.
- Yeah, because some of
the people you interviewed,
that's a hefty amount of forgiving.
- I know, these names are like
Elizabeth Smart, Sue Klebold,
Pablo Escobar's son, Sebastián Marroquín,
and we have so many incredible,
amazing people in the book
and just a really wide range of stories
which was really important to me,
people from all different
backgrounds, all walks of life,
all different faiths, some with no faith.
So, it was important to me to
get a good mixture of people
who've experienced a variety of different,
- [Kelly] It's inclusive.
- Yeah, and so somebody can
read it and relate to something
and also, I encourage
people to kind of pick it up
and put it down because it is a lot.
- [Kelly] A heavy read?
- Yeah, it's a heavy read but
it's also really inspiring
because people gave me the gift
of just really being so open
and honest and raw and vulnerable with me
which was incredible
and now with anybody
who gets to read it, so.
- Have y'all, do you feel
like you've ever had dig deep
to like forgive someone, I have.
- I'm not really great at forgiving.
I probably need to read the book.
- [Kelly] I probably need
to read the book (laughs).
- I'll have him over for dinner
and just talk about it some more.
- Hey, you're eleven but hey,
a lot of people count kids out
but a lot of things
happen when you're a kid
that can be devastating.
Like, I mean my girl's five years old
and she has had her heart broken already
just by friendships, you know?
- Exactly!
- Yeah, all the sudden,
some girl's just mean to her
out of no where and she's like,
"Wait, I thought we were friends."
So you know, that's pretty devastating.
- I know, it is like a,
especially this generation,
I feel like too many
kids are worried about
how other people see them instead of
how they see their self.
- It's a daily conversation
I have with my daughter.
- And they feel like they have
to fit in and match everybody
and it's just like that's how it is.
Like, either you're in
the group or you're out
and it's like, it shouldn't be that way,
you should just accept
everybody for you know,
how they are and that's
how you have real friends,
if you're the real you, yeah.